what's up guys michael here once again
at wisecracks super secret off-site
location to talk about the biggest
lesson millennials have learned since
the 2008 real estate crisis that there's
nothing more fun than watching people
buy houses on tv whether it's identical
twin-lead home makeovers identical twins
who have definitely kissed by the way
quirky cabin renovators or a fixer-upper
power couple slowly building an empire
the fact of the matter is folks under 40
are the primary consumers of channels
like hgtv and the magnolia network and
it isn't just about television younger
adults are gawking at dream homes and
turnkey disasters on instagram tick tock
pinterest and of course on websites like
street easy realtor.com trulia and
perhaps the most infamous of them all
zillow i'd never live in north carolina
but if i did
i could buy a big
gross mansion
but why are we so glued to these visions
of property is it all escapist fantasy
for homes we'll never be able to afford
are these forays actually preparing us
for the realities of the american real
estate landscape or is our obsession
with real estate shows and online
listings inadvertently helping us to dig
our own property grade let's find out in
this wisecrack edition home ownership
what went wrong americans have coveted
property since the first europeans laid
claim to this already inhabited land in
fact taking a nod from philosopher john
locke the declaration of independence
touted every human being's inalienable
right to life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness but here's the catch lock was
better known for his thoughts on the
right to property and for his
complicated views on the pursuit of
happiness thus thomas jefferson's phrase
of choice has often been interpreted to
mean
property and we can only assume that the
founding fathers would have been huge
hgtv fans because they like to watch
brothers kiss the good news was there
was plenty of land in north america for
disaffected europeans to plant flags and
finally call dibs on their own property
this was in stark contrast to the
situation back home as historian gordon
s wood wrote land was scarce in relation
to people and therefore was expensive
hence unable to afford their own land to
farm europeans were compelled to work
for others either by becoming laborers
for landowners in the countryside or
more often by migrating to the cities to
engage in manufacturing goods and
factories because it was easy to find
people to fill both kinds of jobs
wages sucked as a result a lot of
underpaid non-property-owning european
workers put off marriage and kids wow
putting off marriage and kids because
you can't make enough money that would
never happen to anyone i know
i wish i had kids they would love me but
i don't and even though the founding
fathers may have hated the oppressive
system they fled
they somewhat recreated it it's like how
you work your whole life not to become
your parents but you look in the mirror
one day and you realize you're just like
them under capitalism property ownership
does equal liberty at least to some
degree we want to live where everyone
else vacations homeownership in america
is the best way to build generational
wealth so if your family historically
did not have access to property for
reasons
you have a much smaller chance of upward
mobility than people whose families have
been able to use homes as assets equity
and inheritances having trouble paying
down a debt if you're a homeowner you
could refinance or take out a second
mortgage if you're not you can
i don't know like sell bodily fluids
according to the federal reserve the
median net worth for homeowners in 2019
was 250 000
compared to a paltry 6
300
for renters if you're a homeowner it's
also likely that you live around a lot
of other homeowners that means you and
your neighbors are paying property taxes
into the local schools that result in
better funding than neighborhoods with
lower income and higher proportions of
renters so your kids not only likely
benefit from generational wealth but
from a better education and what a cool
system where the quality of a child's
education is tied to property tax rates
in their neighborhood
i see no problems with this and let's
not forget the property ownership was
used for deliberately exclusionary
purposes
like restricting voting rights to
minorities and women in fact even white
men who didn't own property were often
disenfranchised from the voting process
until the mid 19th century as catherine
levine einstein and maxwell palmer point
out even today homeowners dominate
contemporary local politics they
participate at far higher rates are
electorally powerful and comprise
virtually all elected officials even in
cities with large majorities of renters
their disproportionate influence comes
with stark consequences for american
local governments land use and housing
policies that favor the interest of
homeowners have spurred high housing
costs sprawling and environmentally
destructive land use racial and economic
segregation and unequal access to high
quality public goods at the
constitutional convention the question
of whether you needed to own property to
participate politically was hotly
contested and folks like future
president james madison argued only land
owners could be trusted with our
delicate republic see in madison's mind
realistically most americans would never
own property and if all those unproperty
people banded together and say
voted in unison well that would be bad
news bears for the upper crust but like
what if we did that for real though
others at the convention like kite
enthusiast benjamin franklin disagreed
concerned that land ownership as a
condition of electoral participation
would create a powerful aristocracy and
powerless lower class besides many in
the latter group he pointed out had
fought in the recent revolution that
allowed these guys to even be having
this conversation ultimately the
constitution ended up with little to say
about property and decisions about
whether you needed to own property to
vote were left to individual states who
got cruelly creative as we moved forward
and especially in the jim crow era local
restrictions on voting and political
participation increased at the same time
discriminatory housing policies made it
incredibly difficult for pretty much
anyone who wasn't a white male to own
anything at all the emphasis on property
ownership as the paragon of american
virtue was intentionally designed to
benefit one class of people to the
exclusion of all others so in some ways
owning your little piece of land has
always been crucial to success in
america at the same time it's remained
an elusive dream for so many and today
that includes older millennials they
remain deeply impacted by the 2008
financial crisis that saw millions of
americans lose homes to predatory
subprime lending practices and they saw
good-paying jobs disappear almost
overnight and of course they're further
saddled with an unprecedented amount of
student loan debt which really counts
into your white picket fence budget
or your food budget
rent budget toothpaste budget just your
budget as a whole because you don't have
any money and that's not great because
studies have shown that renting is
literally bad for your health a 2012
study of urban homeowners and renters
reported that homeowners perceived a
sense of control trust in neighbors and
residential stability that resulted in
better mental health outcomes than their
renting counterparts unsurprisingly the
lack of stability that has defined
millennial adulthood leads to depression
anxiety and a fertile landscape of
instagram and tick tock therapy but then
the pandemic hit and while cooped up in
tiny apartments we started gazing
longingly at the internet listings of
homes with yards room for an office and
enough space to escape the scent of our
roommates deteriorating hygiene habits
you know how i am about my gas range but
as young people flocked to the internet
to ogle their dream home one of the main
purveyors of hashtag house goals content
found itself in hot water for deeply
anti-consumer practices and it managed
to also royally screw itself in an
ill-conceived effort to profit even
further off the home selling process
that website
is zillow and if you're between the ages
of 25 and 40 you've probably lost at
least one afternoon to it are you bored
launched in 2006 zillow began as a
simple listings website where users
could put in specs for homes they wanted
to buy things like location budget
numbers of bedrooms and bathrooms etc i
go to open houses because i love seeing
how other people live then they could
connect with a broker when they saw
something they liked according to will
parker of the wall street journal it's a
platform for real estate agents to find
people who are looking for homes and
want to buy them that's the primary way
that zillow makes money and it's a good
business it's very high margins and so
it's not a very capital or asset
intensive business side note if you want
to learn more about how platforms
function check out our recent video on
elon musk but in 2018 the company
decided to cut out the middleman and
start buying and selling homes directly
a practice called instant buying or
eye buying because when you put i in
front of anything it makes it fancy and
they predicted it would make them in
real estate terms a metric but full of
money journalist ryan knutson put it
this way with eye buying consumers could
skip the long hassle of listing a home
showing it waiting for offers
negotiating and so on and instead sell
their home almost instantly to a company
like zillow zillow thought this model
would be more attractive to buyers and
sellers and as parker points out even if
the price zillow offered for your house
was lower than its market value the
convenience of the transaction and the
promise that the deal would go through
quickly was attractive enough to lure in
more sellers and grow zillow's inventory
in essence zillow was simply home
flipping a practice any hgtv viewer is
familiar with the asking price was 390
000 and we wound up paying 9 billion
plus closing costs
ideally zillow would buy homes and then
sell them for more than they purchased
them on top of that ibuyers bringing
money through transaction fees the real
cash cow in the deal zillow predicted
that their eye buying scheme which they
called zillow offers would rake in an
extra 20 billion dollars a year but
house flipping isn't that lucrative on a
small scale you can't say buy a house
for a hundred thousand and sell it for a
million the margin between buying costs
and selling profits is relatively small
so in order to live up to the massive
promise of a multi-billion dollar surge
in revenue zillow had to go big or go
home or go big
and get homes and that's exactly what
they did zillow snapped up 7 000 homes
at prices that baffled their competitors
and in many cases delighted homeowners
who were putting their houses on the
market zillow would sometimes pay more
than the price at which local real
estate agents had valued the homes in
order to entice the seller to make an
easy and quick decision and this
practice inspired a now viral tick tock
where real estate agent sean gotcher
posits why would they pay 340
for this 31st home whenever they've only
paid 300 for these others
well what that just did is create a new
comp so when they go to sell these other
30 homes
that extra 40 000 you could say this one
sold for 340
just made them 1.2 million of course
zillow tried to shoot down these
insinuations in a statement to yahoo
news claiming that we pay market value
for every home we purchase when we
looked at homes that sold traditionally
after they declined a zillow offer we
learned that on average those selling
traditionally sold for only .09
more than the zillow offer and if we
learned anything about corporate pr we
can always trust exactly what they say
but quibbles overpriced fiction aside
zillow's plan had a few kinks real
estate isn't a costco and snapping up
houses in bulk is considerably riskier
than impulse buying those five-ton
cartons of pizza-flavored goldfish
although realistically
both are going to leave you with some
regrets and in the fall of 2021 regret
hit hard when zillow announced that it
had taken a half billion dollar loss on
zillow offers which if you're counting
is 20 and a half billion dollars less
than the profit they'd expected it's
hard not to laugh at zillow's hubris but
it's instructive to consider what
they're planning to do with all those
houses and spoiler alert they're not
selling them to families or newlyweds
according to bloomberg news zillow is
pitching them to institutional investors
like private equity firms and this whole
debacle is really a microcosm of a much
larger problem in america in the
aftermath of the 2008 housing crisis
huge corporate investors started
scooping up houses that had been
dispossessed and renting them out often
for more than residents would have paid
otherwise this practice has ramped up
aggressively since with corporations
like blackstone pouring billions of
dollars into real estate and yielding
record profits for example in atlanta
last year 17 of single-family homes were
bought by large corporate investors
according to atlanta studies see big
corporations are often willing to take
big risks and big losses on properties
something the average individual or
family can't afford at the same time by
artificially constraining the supply of
real estate in america these
corporations have driven prices sky high
as such neighborhood dynamics are
upended as families and businesses are
priced out of their communities and
we're not alone in this america's maple
syrup soaked neighbors to the north are
experiencing something similar canadian
publication the walrus illustrated the
problem with the story of s.w welch an
independent used bookstore in montreal
when the building house in the bookstore
was bought by a real estate firm 68 year
old stephen welch was informed that the
store's rent taxes insurance and
maintenance would increase to 5 000 a
month a staggering 150 percent
unable to afford the surge welch said
simply i think they'd rather the
building be empty than have me here and
increasingly this is true throughout the
united states as well for a real estate
firm that can afford to buy up
properties in lucrative locations and
leave them empty it's a waiting game as
executive director of downtown montreal
business association glenn costinera
explained say a landlord buys a property
with a mom and pop shop that pays its
rent on time every month but it only
pays one thousand dollars the landlord
may think he can get five thousand or
ten thousand per month even if the
property remains vacant for 10 months it
only takes one month's rent with the new
tenant to make back what they lost
some cities have created taxes and fees
to penalize firms who leave usable
property vacant for extended periods of
time but real estate speculation the act
of buying a property in anticipation of
favorable changes in the market has
proven too profitable to be shut down
especially by slaps on the wrist like
oakland california's 6 000 a year flat
fee for homes in use fewer than 50 days
a year and in a red-hot housing market
some 16 million homes still remain
vacant throughout the united states the
injustice of there being 16 million
vacant homes in a country with half a
million unhoused people is pretty
staggering meanwhile since the recession
the value of american real estate has
ballooned at an unprecedented rate but
remember lots of homeowners lost their
houses during the crisis so instead of
these gains going to moderate or
middle-income homeowners it's going into
the coffers of huge corporations and
their shareholders and it's all fun
games and easy television for our
glowing surrogates and their newly
remodeled happily ever afters but when
you turn the tv off the reality is a lot
darker one survey referenced in fortune
showed that some 82 percent of
millennials have at least one
significant regret about buying a home
including decreasing home values
neighborhoods that turn out to be a bad
fit and the decidedly unglamorous
realities of fixer-uppers meanwhile
foreclosure spiked a staggering 700 in
january 2022 according to data company
black knight this picture doesn't quite
square with the cheery antics of
christina on the coast so what about the
majority of us left window shopping on
zillow fantasizing about the day we too
will join the ranks of landowners in
some ways we're cosplaying a dream in
stark contrast to reality put
differently we're situating ourselves
squarely within a system
that's rendered us pretty powerless iris
marion young contends that the goal of a
dream house sets workers working and
keeps workers working fearing job loss
working overtime the consumer-driven
desire of civic privatism tends to
produce political quietism that is to
say when we're really worried about
finding our own single-family house
we're gonna work our butts off instead
of questioning the political system that
puts us in this position as sociologist
david madden and urban planner peter
marcuzza write in their book in defense
of housing ownership restricts household
members opportunities to engage in other
activities as well as their desires to
do so especially their willingness to
participate in collective action that
might involve social conflict when we're
more focused on benefiting from a shitty
system we're less likely to agitate
against that system at the same time the
writers argue that this individualist
thinking means that if something goes
wrong the individual is thought to be to
blame rather than social and political
structures the fact that so many
millennials can't buy a house or can't
keep up with their mortgage payments
isn't because they're blowing they're
not keeping up with inflation wages on
avocado toast it's because they're being
priced out by huge corporations zillow's
accessibility belies that reality and
keeps us dreaming and that's what makes
it so seductive but what do you guys
think are you still going to spend your
friday nights on a hot date with the
zillow listings and a rerun of property
brothers or is real estate porn actually
a lot more sinister than the other twins
that do real estate might have you think
let us know in the comments huge thanks
to all our patrons and if you haven't
checked it out in a while check out our
patreon page we have a lot of cool new
stuff there um also check out our new
stream wisecrack live every thursday
right here hit that subscribe button
like you're clicking buy on the zillow
listing for the french riviera castle of
your dreams and don't forget to ring
that bell and as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
you